this is the police cordon that's
currently in place it's about half a
mile or so away from the crash site so
police have closed off quite a large
area here there's only a couple of minor
roads that go past the crash site which
means that quite a large area has had to
be sealed off by police the fire service
and police are still on site at the
moment from our aerial pictures we can
see the actual scene of the crash it
looks as though it's a very limited
crash radius we can see a blue tent
close to a tree that appears to have
been burnt out with what appears to be
wreckage at its base the fire service
still on site there with no indication
as yet to the cause of the crash we know
that it happened just before noon today
i've spoken to a couple of local
residents here didn't hear the crash one
of them was actually on a tractor at the
time he's a hill farmer here but he said
that he did seem the plumes of smoke
which were emitting from the crash site
shortly afterwards we believe that the
that the aircraft the helicopter crashed
shortly after taking off from a property
somewhere in the very near vicinity to
the actual crash site and we know that
two people were on board and sadly both
those people have been pronounced dead
by north yorkshire police they say that
specially trained officers are currently
dealing with their families the fact
that they said families perhaps suggests
that these are people from two separate
households but no details have yet been
given us to the ages or sex of the
people who've been involved in this
tragic incident the air accident
investigators will shortly take over
control of the scene or will soon take
over control of the scene to carry out
their investigations the two main
thrusts of which normally at this stage
will be either pilot error or mechanical
failure but those investigations can
take some time and it could be days
weeks or even months before the full
cause of the crash is announced by those
air accidents investigators they will be
on the scene
for the next few days in the meantime as
i say two people killed and especially
trained police officers from north
yorkshire police currently dealing with
their very distraught families